[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso oriente El magacín
quincena de France 24 en el que les
acercamos las historias de medio oriente
América Latina Esto es lo que veremos
hoy la mitad de un país lo adora la otra
mitad lo detesta el polémico erdoan se
enfrenta el domingo a unos comicios que
podrían marcar el fin de sus 20 años de
gobierno
y Siria volvió a la liga árabe y desató
la rabia entre la oposición dentro y
fuera del país 12 años después de la
guerra lassad retoma su agenda
internacional pese a las acusaciones de
crímenes de lesa humanidad en su contra
y violaciones a los derechos humanos
y se cumple un año del asesinato de la
periodista palestino estadounidense
sirin a boagle una tragedia nacional que
conmocionó al mundo y cuya muerte sigue
en la impunidad
[Música]
iniciamos en Turquía este domingo el
país vive las elecciones presidenciales
y parlamentarias más reñidas en las
últimas dos décadas son una prueba para
el actual presidente y candidato a la
reelección
quien lleva 20 años en el poder dado que
por primera vez la oposición tiene
posibilidades reales de vencer veamos un
gráfico sobre el sistema electoral hay
64 millones de electores turcos en una
población de casi 85 millones en julio
de 2018 Turquía pasó de ser un sistema
parlamentario a uno presidencial los
votantes eligen ahora directamente al
presidente y queda así abolida la figura
del Primer Ministro dando un mayor poder
al presidente vencedor también El
vencedor necesita lograr la mayoría
absoluta sin nadie la alcanza los dos
principales candidatos se enfrentarán a
una segunda vuelta dos semanas después
el presidente también gobernará por un
período de cinco años y podrá ser
reelegido nuevamente además se elige a
600 miembros de la gran asamblea o
parlamento por un sistema de
representación proporcional para evitar
un parlamento sin mayoría y la
fragmentación política solo los partidos
con al menos el 10% de los votos a nivel
nacional en las legislativas tienen
derecho a presentarse sin duda la crisis
económica y la economía pondrán a prueba
al próximo presidente y juega un papel
clave en las votaciones la crisis
financiera podría pasarle factura a
erdoan a lo que se suma una inflación
disparada que golpea la canasta básica o
al acceso a la salud y a las medicinas y
una caída de la lira turca que continúa
perdiendo su valor frente al Euro y al
Dólar veamos más sobre estos retos
económicos en el siguiente informe
muchos turcos que se preparan para votar
en las elecciones generales del domingo
ya no votarán a recepta allí Perdón para
este barbero afincado en Estambul todo
se debe a la política económica del
gobierno
[Música]
Yo diría que los responsables son los
que nos gobiernan toman todas las
decisiones sobre la economía y el país
creo que han tomado decisiones
equivocadas antes era partidario del akp
pero ya no creo que les vote
erdogan se enfrenta a la mayor amenaza a
su presidencia desde que fue elegido un
programa económico que ha llevado al
gobierno a recortar los tipos de interés
en lugar de subirlos lo que ha provocado
una crisis del coste de la vida así como
una moneda debilitada erdogan de 69 años
logró mantener una sólida base de
votantes gracias al crecimiento
económico de su primera década de
gobierno pero desde su reelección en
2018 la inflación se ha disparado en
abril cayó al 43,7% pero alcanzó un
máximo del 85,5% en octubre del año
pasado de hecho a finales de 2022
Turquía tenía el cuarto nivel de
inflación más alto del mundo solo por
detrás de zimbabwe Venezuela y Sudán la
lira turca ha caído un 76% durante el
último mandato de erdogan y los precios
de los alimentos siguen subiendo un 54%
en abril de este año en comparación con
el anterior a pesar de todos estos
factores no todo el mundo está dispuesto
a culpar al presidente
la inflación es muy difícil para
nosotros pero la gente es culpable de
esto no es culpa de erdogan algunos
sondeos muestran ardogan por detrás de
que mal kris daroglu antes de la
votación de la primera vuelta del
domingo Aunque la diferencia sea
reducido recientemente la principal
amenaza para la continuidad es el
candidato de la alianza de partidos que
malquistaroku el líder del partido
popular republicano de Centro izquierda
quiere abolir el sistema presidencial y
fortalecer al parlamento y reconstruir
también y entregar viviendas gratis por
ejemplo a los damnificados por los
sismos entre sus propuestas también está
el de acercar sus posturas con la Unión
Europea y Estados Unidos veamos otros de
los desafíos que enfrentará el próximo
presidente Turco los masivos terremotos
del 6 de febrero que dejaron más de
50.000 muertos en el sureste de Turquía
y unos 2,7 millones de desplazados han
hecho Mella en las campañas políticas ya
que también afectaron un 16% de la
población si bien el presidente Dual fue
fuertemente criticado por la gestión de
la catástrofe y muchos lo acusan de
permitir obras que no cumplían con todos
los requisitos lo que habría magnificado
esta tragedia este será sin duda un tema
sensible para los próximos cinco años de
gobierno por otro lado sumado al fuerte
sentimiento nacionalista y a la crisis
económicas en los últimos años se ha
incrementado la desaprobación y los
casos de violencia y abusos contra los
refugiados sirios que intentan
sobrevivir en Turquía los candidatos
opositores Proponen devolver a los
sirios más de 3,7 millones de refugiados
a su país de origen con la mediación Eso
sí te Damasco y un país cada vez más
pegado al islamismo y alejado de la
modernidad con la que erdoan inició su
carrera política las mujeres están
relegadas a un segundo plano en la vida
política sólo cuatro tienen posibilidad
reales de llegar al parlamento
cambiamos de tema más de unas década de
guerra en Siria que derivó en la
expulsión de Damasco de la influyente
liga árabe pasear al azar volvió a ser
admitido en la organización un paso más
en la normalización de las relaciones
con sus vecinos Pese a que el dictador
quien controla la mayor parte de Siria
fue acusado de crímenes de guerra y
violaciones de Derechos Humanos durante
el conflicto y para analizar la
importancia de este restablecimiento de
relaciones tenemos a Susana mangana
analista política internacional Gracias
por estar en France 24 Susana Cómo logró
a la Sad esta reintegración que hay
detrás de este ingreso Y si está
buscando a SAT ayudas internacionales
para reconstruir un país en ruinas
Sí bueno efectivamente la readmisión de
Siria en la Liga de estado árabe que es
el órgano supranacional que tienen los
Países Árabes para dirimir sus
conflictos pero en ese cometido ha sido
evidentemente muy fracaso no
evidentemente nefasta la actuación de la
liga árabe a lo largo de las últimas
décadas no obstante como tú decías es un
organismo influyente en la región lo que
ha hecho es valerse del momento en el
que están viviendo las relaciones
internacionales con una coyuntura que
tenemos instalada en la Guerra de
Ucrania Rusia y por tanto ha habido un
acercamiento del mundo árabe al régimen
de alasad toda vez que han caído en la
cuenta países como Arabia saudí o la
propia Turquía también en la región de
que no era el final del dictador sino
que tienen que aprender a volver a
convivir con él pues porque no había un
plan recambio para basar al azar Susana
y Qué consecuencias puede tener esta
reincorporación para la población civil
Siria también para la escasa oposición
dentro del país Bueno evidentemente como
ya nos esperábamos ha habido unas
declaraciones muy altisonantes muy
rimbombantes de que le van a exigir una
una serie de condiciones a basar a la
SAT sobre todo transitar en esa hoja de
ruta de Naciones Unidas para poner fin
al conflicto sirio que ya está vigente
desde el 2015 y pocos avances ha habido
pero yo creo que para la población Siria
lo que urge hoy es ver si va a cambiar
la tónica el diálogo con unas
autoridades que tienen que facilitar el
regreso de millones de refugiados que
todavía están desperdigados por la
geografía de oriente medio sobre todo en
el país vecino Turquía pero también en
Jordania o en el Líbano y en Egipto y
darse las condiciones para que puedan
volver con seguridad a sus poblaciones
natales sin sufrir represalias del
régimen eso es algo muy importante para
la población pero cuando hablamos de
oposición como tú decías no solo es casi
inexistente porque se la ha aniquilado o
bien se la ha asesinado está obligado al
exilio forzoso pero no han hablado de
incorporar a la etnia kurda que como
sabemos es parte del paisaje del puzzle
étnico y confesional de Siria y sin
incorporar a los kurdos al diálogo con
las autoridades de Siria pues nunca
vamos a tener una paz duradera
sostenible en el tiempo en aquel país y
Susana muy brevemente en los últimos
años Siria se ha convertido en un
narcoestado con su producción de
píldoras captagón algo que preocupa por
ejemplo a los países del Golfo Por qué
le interesa a los miembros de la liga
árabe está entrada de Siria
les interesa porque de alguna manera
prefieren tener en su redil y cercanos a
ellos a un país que ha estado bajo la
bota militar de Irán pero que además
tiene muy fuerte dependencia de la
República islámica de Irán que es el
archienemigo de las monarquías
petroleras árabes Es decir de esta
manera todos ganan Arabia saudí emiratos
árabes Unidos o el propio Egipto tienen
cerca a basar a las app que necesita Sí
o sí reanudar tu relación su vínculo con
los Hermanos árabes Pues de esta manera
también se da por enterrada el hacha de
guerra determina el conflicto sirio a
nivel internacional porque ya no se
espera que caiga su régimen con lo cual
todo salen ganando Arabia saudí tiene
más cerca de su protección pero también
de su control al disco lo del mundo
árabe que es basar a la sati Siria que
son cercanos a Irán y por otro lado va a
ser al asad es reincorporado remitido en
la Liga de Estados árabe con lo cual ya
los árabes no esperan que su régimen
termine Susana mangana Muchísimas
gracias por este análisis y por estar
con nosotros en France 24 y se cumple el
primer aniversario del asesinato de
shein a wacle la periodista de alyazira
que recibió un disparo en la cabeza
durante su cobertura de una redada
israelí en la cisj Jordania ocupada un
año después su crimen sigue impune la
historia nos la trae en nuestros
corresponsales Yanira Gómez Muñoz y
Federico cué Barberena
el legado de chirina buakle sigue vivo
hoy se celebra una misa en honor a la
reportera Palestina estadounidense
asesinada hace un año cuando cubría una
redada del ejército israelí en yin
familiares y amigos siguen reclamando
que su muerte no quede impune
este último año fue muy difícil para
nosotros especialmente sabiendo que no
se ha hecho justicia aún esa única bala
que la mató nos dejó con dolor y agonía
Deseando que todo fuera un mal sueño
me siento como si fuera el primer día es
muy duro pero Seguiremos adelante porque
ese es el mensaje de shein
mujer cristiana periodista así
reivindica a sherim su sobrinalina
apoyada en testigos e investigaciones de
medios y de la ONU culpa del crimen a un
francotirador israelí Aunque Israel
admitió la responsabilidad de un soldado
como alta probabilidad se niega a
iniciar una causa judicial lo que obligó
a la familia a recurrir a la Corte Penal
Internacional
todavía estamos esperando respuesta del
fiscal con la esperanza de que tome este
caso ya que constituye un crimen de
guerra bajo la ley internacional
queremos que el soldado se haga
responsable y también la persona que le
ordenó apretar el gatillo rendir cuentas
se traduce en acciones y eso es lo que
aún no hemos visto
es lo que exige el sindicato de
periodistas palestinos
su presidente explica que shirin es una
de los 55 reporteros muertos desde el
año 2000 y denuncia que solo en 2022
hubo 902 agresiones contra la prensa
todo periodista que quiere transmitir la
verdad es objeto de ataques y crímenes
nosotros sufrimos un dos veces por los
asesinatos y los crímenes y por el
silencio de la comunidad internacional
reconocida en vida soy un símbolo para
los palestinos que le dedican grafitis
monumentos y hasta una calle en ramala
así mantienen la memoria de la voz de
Palestina llegamos al si hay al final de
esta edición de Expreso Oriente Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos y los invito a
enviar sus comentarios a las redes
sociales que aparecen en sus pantallas y
a seguir toda la información en nuestra
página web France 24.com
[Música]